the casualty toll is rising fast as
Moroccans begin the heartbreaking duty
of burying their
dead the 6.8 magnitude earthquake is the
worst to hit the region in over a 100
years I was asleep when the earthquake
struck I could not Escape because the
roof fell on me I was trapped I was
saved by my neighbors who cleared the
rubble with their bare hands now I'm
living with them in their house because
mine was completely
destroyed but as some bid their final
goodbyes others are in a race against
time to reach survivors under the rubble
the International Federation of the Red
Cross says the next 48 to 72 hours will
be crucial but it's no easy task
especially in isolated and mountainous
communities search and rescue efforts
will be absolutely prioritized in
parallel of course with making sure that
those that did survive uh are taken care
of in terms of their basic
needs government officials are among the
able-bodied volunteers involved in
search and rescue efforts the injured
and the trapped can only hope that help
is on the way cues have formed outside
blood donation centers throughout
Morocco we are all Brothers these are
difficult times and this is why we came
here this is the least we can do some
lost loved ones some lost their homes
thank God for everything we must come
together to give the victims a hand a
Royal Decree has been issued declaring 3
days of national mourning while many
residents have yet to come to terms with
the new reality of rubble and despair
around them here in the historic city of
Marakesh despite clear evidence that an
earthquake has taken place mercifully
much of its infrastructure remains
unscathed not so Southwest of here in
the high Atlas Mountains where the
epicenter of this Quake was felt there
communities in hard-to-reach rural areas
will likely largely be fending for
themselves it may yet be some time
before the true scope and scale of This
Disaster is known jonal Al jazer
Marakesh make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer